forget for a moment Ron DeSantis who's
done a great job on crime and Law and
Order down in Florida
let's turn it up a notch a little bit
let's take a look down at El Salvador
El Salvador not known for being the
safest place in the world
probably not where you want to go
honeymoon and yet
El Salvador has had
it's a miracle political program over
the last couple of years El Salvador's
murder rate has plummeted by 50 percent
El Salvador with a new a new president
president naib bukili
has had its its murder rate tumble
56.8 percent in 2022 alone
how did El Salvador do that
it wanted to do that it it wanted to fix
the murder problem
it mustered the political will to do it
and then the president
affecting this policy sent in troops to
go round up MS-13 like the animals that
they are they just released a propaganda
video it's an amazing propaganda video
so you see the MS-13 gangsters in this
prison this super max prison you've got
these MS-13 gangsters
they've got their heads down
for they're all crouched over they look
like
insects or they're all tatted up in
green they've got their heads down below
their hands the guards all have black
masks on presumably because the guards
don't want MS-13 to go murder all their
families they're just standing in their
boxer shorts The Reason by the way that
they're shirtless I think is to show
that they're all just tatted up and all
this green some sometimes occult imagery
if demons were incarnate it would be
these guys and yet when they're outside
the clink they look so tough right that
people are encouraged to join these
these types of gangs because they think
it'll it'll get them money and women and
status and yet what the president has
done here is cram them all into this
extremely high security prison round
them up like animals I think he he
rounded up something like 65 000 of
these criminals threw them all in prison
and then he didn't just stop there he
created a very slick highly produced
propaganda video
humiliating them
and then he put that out there for all
the world to see
we need we need to learn from El
Salvador never thought I would say that
sentence but we in the United States
need to follow the lead of the
government of El Salvador
we need to be clear that if you commit
crimes you will be punished for it
there's really basic stuff that we all
used to know one of the arguments
against capital punishment is that it
doesn't actually deter crime
and the studies that suggest it doesn't
actually deter crime or a little bit
suspect but let's take them at face
value let's say it's true that capital
punishment today does not really deter
crime
what would the surprise be there we
don't really carry out capital
punishment the way it's carried out is
completely haphazard most of the time
some lib Governor will just let
everybody off the hook
or some Court will pretend like capital
punishment is cruel and unusual
punishment it's neither
and so even if there is a conviction for
capital punishment it's not going to
disturb crime because people don't
believe that they're actually going to
carry it out
if you had a country right now
where the president
attended a capital punishment let's say
there were capital punishment at the
federal level a federal inmate is going
to be executed and the president not
only didn't grant clemency but showed up
as the face of Justice in America
that would do a lot to deter crime
and what the libs and the squishes would
say is they would say this is
this is cruel this is inhumane this is
authoritarian it's Authority that's what
they are saying in fact the New Yorker
says the rise of naive bukhili's Elsa of
El Salvador's authoritarian president oh
he's so it's a repressive Crackdown
listen to what they say they say the
budding strong man has written Bitcoin
schemes
and a repressive Crackdown on gangs
to become Latin America's most popular
leader
can you be repressive
against gangs
I guess I guess so I guess you can
repress The Gangs but that seems like
that is actually liberative of the
people it's not repressive on the people
when you when you go after these
criminals when you go after these
gangsters
it represses that group
and it frees the other group
that's why he's Latin America's most
popular leader
it's authoritarian he's wielding
authority to do good to get the bad guys
and to help the good guys we should be
doing that too
and mentioned on the show
a week or two ago I said there are two
words you got to write them down if
you're driving wait until you pull over
I don't want you to get in a car
accident the two the two phrases you've
got to write down are big government and
authoritarian
those are words that today don't mean
anything
authoritarian is just a word that the
Liberals use when conservatives wield
political power ever
we should be doing that we should do
that a lot more we should take some real
lessons
from naive bukili I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing his name
what he is showing us is that the law is
a teacher
we've known this all the way back to the
ancient Greeks the law is a teacher
so we on the American right we like to
say politics is Downstream of culture
and that is true to a certain extent the
movies affect the government the way the
way that law is made no question about
it I think daily wire has actually shown
that pretty clearly in the battle over
transgenderism among other battles
but the law also affects politics and
the law is also a teacher
and when the law
sends an army to your door and rounds up
your gang like the animals that they are
you're going to get fewer gangsters and
they're going to commit fewer crimes and
that's going to change the culture and
that's a good thing it's music Monday
baby we got to get on over to the member
block uh Ben Davies has given me a song
that he he wants me to throw all of my
pop culture prowess onto and I'm willing
to do that we will see you there if
you're not a member why not are you just
one of those hoi polloi out there
perusing this show on YouTube for free
you got to go to dailywire.com
use code Knowles at checkout to get two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign